bienvenue dans cette vidéo dans laquelle
nous allons boire du thé durant des
heures durant à à excuser on serait
aujourd'hui sur alésia the dark descent
un personnalisé l'histoire des scans
wade une custom toriques vous êtes
nombreux à avoir conseillé selanne et
1898 et votre nom est john martin vous
êtes fous torturés ou jason si je sais
pas parler anglais
va te faire voyager par l'anglais mais
très mal bon alors j'espère que vous
avez tous voté avec vous est ce que
croyait croyez moi il va finir sur votre
écran un vus ce jeu est possible de
commencer du dos comme ça ce possible
chargement alors c'est parti
nous voici donc dans une pièce que je ne
connais pas un
alors moi on va ouvrir ce tiroir pour
commencer comme ça ouais et qui voter
bon allez c'était pas une théière c'est
pasqua là
et alors on va vrai le second tiroirs
oui nous avons une boîte d'amadou
j'adore amadou moi je vais toujours
comme ça avec avec un petit accent ben
jawad où je trouve que ça sonne comme un
mot afrique et en fait amadou bon bref
alors est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas
quelque chose là dedans dutil à une
chemise
oui on va se faire tout bon pour les
monstres énorme ce tableau pas le bouger
non pas le bouger
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
à
non non non non non non non non non non
non c'est interdit y'a plus de thé ya
plus de thé hockey
laisse-moi par terre cabade voilà
rockets 0 à bordel c'est un rsa du coup
j'ai pu voir qu'il y avait à bordel ça
va être super du rachat attraper ce truc
là n'ont regardé tri yes we three qu on
a faim trith
allez c'est parti on continue ya plein
de cette pièce un donc ça c'était où
vous salut toi coquine tu veux moudre
les schémas bon alors il ya encore des
bruits stressant [ __ ] mais c'est très
simple jeu bordel 2 et des bruits de
souris dre qu'il ya quelqu'un qui fait à
la porte alors et non c'est fermé ah que
coucou où on y va allez c'est parti
qu'est ce qu'on va voir dans ses coffres
tiens brossette manette et dégage le
monstre qui faisait le moins peur au
monde où il ya de la mode doux il ya
beaucoup de jobs à tous et en plus on
est une clé magnifique a par contre lui
l'état tiens prends cette deuxième
manette et dégage allez vas t'en aller
au samba arrêtez s'il vous plaît
laissez-moi tranquille
j'aime pas les armures j'aime pas les
armures on va mettre la bague du
seigneur des anneaux
elle sera avec nous alors est-ce qu'on
peut pas
déjà fermé cette porte voilà faire
[ __ ] un an der mur on s'en fout de
vous alors qu'est ce que nous allons
avoir un tableau glauque quelques alors
c'est une eau froide une offrande d'un
tableau moche bon alors on a de lui là
on va pouvoir voir notre petit nom wata
phoque n'a fait perçu là et s'il ya toi
aussi tu veux de manette pour allez
tiens c'est bon quoi allez dégagez là
vous êtes chiens ont fait une pinata
cette porte là elle est ferme et mon
oncle et parce qu'on peut pas l'ouvrir à
l'aide de cette superbe clef pièce
bonjour c'est un bras voilà merci
allez au revoir merci même plus
sérieusement on a un torse bon on a de
l'huile de la match ou encore de l'huile
et un sac un sac de courgettes un
magnifique
allez c'est bon c'est parti on arrête de
faire durer le suspense on ouvre la
porte
salut je déjà donné pas mal et
atteignait ya des pétales qui volent
c'est magnifique c'est très très beau
une on a retrouvé la keller bordel alors
est-ce qu'on peut pas trouver quelque
chose qui ne sera plutôt utile genre
dans ses tiroirs
je suis sûr qu'on va avoir plein de
l'amadou on va être amadou lyonnais re
du laudanum seniors là alors est-ce
qu'on peut pas regarder dans le tiroir
absolument y a rien ici il n'y a
absolument rien non plus
non deux on va prendre cette que le
seigneur jésus christ soit avec nous ta
ta ta ta maman jetons juste mais non
c'est l'heure du christ ok tu ne sers à
passer tout va bien mais tout va bien
mais pourquoi on stresserait pourquoi
stress lyon nous hein y'a pas de raison
[Applaudissements]
ça ça vous rejetez pas quelqu'un une
petite fille c'est faux c'est ma maman d
à ses portes du cri ok pas moi non le
câble de la caméra qui était d'en monter
ça me fera un terrain car mélange de
motets et du mois caméra seulement drôle
nous sommes vraiment des gens super
super drôle alors du coup je suis en
train de nettoyer un [ __ ] de merde
j'ai pas j'ai pas de pq et ben non
voyez on va toujours dedans le pq bon
j'ai un oreiller c'est pas grave c'était
juste a atteint durant le chargement n y
voit là c'est parfait c'est bon la
caméra va bien hop en passant par une
petite gorgée du thé allez on continue
au continua lorsque dans une pièce pas
mal glauque et 1 quand même faut bien le
dire avec un balai ipoker on va jouer au
sport sport avec la boule dorée là bref
alors de la mode bio c'est une la raison
laudanum une scie ne m'a approché plus
beaux rôles de bâtard j'ai aussi des
cochons
c'est mon activité alors voilà je suis
plutôt longs longs jours ses fesses bon
alors est ce qu'il y aurait pas autre
chose
un hold up en paille et salue une boîte
km uh mais je pense qu'on va rater de
ramasser de l'amadou un moment regardez
on a trop d'amadou trop d'amadou tulle
amadou s'était armé complet allumer les
bougies du coup ça c'est peut-être
intéressant il ya encore monsieur man
est un qui est mort restaurant de
torture c'est génial ce guignol ce jeu
bah oui qu'est ce que c'est que ça tient
fallait pas voilà ma manette ma carte
ok on s'en va on s'en va c'est
suffisament route porte de portes
laquelle vous voulez celle-ci d'accord
très bien on va danser
ces deux là ont bien au teint austra
pour moi je suis bête
alors est-ce qu'on peut pas à merde
d'accord donc ça c'est des gros objets
faut se déplacer de manière latérale
constitue l'indus par ici salut c'est
ici la fête les gars à une orgie
oui j'étais sûr que j'étais ici bordel
qu'est ce qu'on peut avoir absolument un
feu on a un feu on a un monstre qui va
pas tarder à arriver je le sens je
l'entends c'est glauque
bah écoutez nous sommes bloqués 1 j'ai
envie de dire dans du vomi non seulement
génial
non sans rire ya forcément du truc à
faire ici ah non rien toujours pas on a
pété un vase nous sommes d'aidé l'accord
[ __ ] bon bah nous allons nous mettre
dans ce placard et nous nous retrouvons
quand j'aurai trouvé la solution le
placard c'est ouvert
je déconne c'est la magie du montage
vont alors à priori je n'ai pas trouvé
il nous allons devoir continuer de
chercher dans cette petite pièce n y
j'ai presque fini monte d'ailleurs en
attendant on va s'attacher de bonnes
notes et on va attendre non aux castes
une mauvaise idée ouais c'est de trouver
à un truc construit [ __ ] mais y'a pas
un bordel de machin de merde un toit
pages de cailloux 0e ce bouquet wall il
est ce qu'on peut on peut pas lire dans
ce district non non non on peut pas lire
un [ __ ] y'a pas portel non mais je
croise les doigts dans le ps à mon avis
doit avoir un passage je ne connaisse
pas possible là y'a rien est ce qu on
pas soulever ce tonneau on ne peut pas
bouger la cheminée je ne pense pas dès
lors un peu lourd ma foi des chaises aux
houillères michel ça peut-être en
sautant dessus
nous faisons du trampoline hier non ok
ça va pas être ça un tapis c'est ce
qu'on veux pas à
owen je suis trop heureux un toboggan
dit oui c'est plutôt que localement en
étant là c'est une mauvaise idée
alors gauche ou droite la majorité un
trouble sont droitiers leur maladroite
bon moi je suis gaucher on aurait dû à
la gauche si c'est pas le bon chemin et
bien la gueule à gauche vaincra
[Musique]
mais pour qui vous prenez banque de
boîtes bordel ya un monstre tabac où je
rêve non c'est une porte ouverte et
what's up commence à hama où une cellule
bordel on va être fermé je bois un petit
coup de vin je m'en fous le premier
ennemi qui s'adresserait à moi il se
prendra un coup de bras
ils ont coincé notre bras rendez nous
notre bras rendez-nous le bras bordel de
merde c'était le nôtre moi non je suis
désolé je veux te voir tu abandonné en
témoin montbrun bordel bon dieu qui est
la barre guerre non c'était beau brad
aurait alors est ce qu'il n'ya pas tu
cherchais tombera il alla tient la voix
la voix si tu veux te des bras
c'est quoi ce escrimeurs l'attend on
peut pas le prendre cet homme non non
bon il a préféré rester aux mains des
toiles de mer je comprendre mais c'est
compréhensible c'est compréhensible
droite ou gauche va cette fois on va à
gauche
1 parce que la gauche y mit de côté
j'aime pas ça je me chie dessus
salut comment tu vois c'est quoi ton
problème
qu'est-ce qui va pas au haut c'est un os
mais c'est un coffre au on aurait au ben
oui bon on fait cuire
on ne fait que tout va bien mais tout va
bien mais tout va bien on mange du porc
charal nouvelle pub cherhal est ce qu'on
peut pas tourner ça c'est pas à quoi ça
sert la roue tourne à la même direction
d'accor et il se passe rien alors sais
pas si c'est un rituel vaudou avec une
vache a mentionné que les photos vous
devriez avoir une vache au coffre et
nourault et une boîte damaggio bombe à
bas les couilles bah écoutez on n'ira
plus à ma gauche un public je vous dise
que voulez-vous que je vous dise nous
avons passé par là bas j'ai oublié
concourait avec l'air la touche maj au
pire on peut pas juste
non alors ça s'ouvre mais ça reste
fermée c'est absolument génial ya
quelqu'un qui fait un bain juste là
c'est pas l'art de la toilette mon pote
mois passés par là bas qu'est ce qu'il
ya pas mal à aller ouvre toi ouvre toi
salut qu'est ce qui se passe ici veut
avoir une clé cachée je pense
gg pauvres et ses trucs de fred et mons
2 dans une clé jamais oui zone
[Musique]
attends pas il est méchant
1 allez on y va on y va on y va on s'en
fout on s'en fout on s'en fout on s'en
fout on s'en fout on s'en fout mais la
clé n'ayez pas peur je me gratte au
bordel vous devez continuer à [ __ ] je
me suis bloqué un truc dans le coup
c'est une blague
what bordel ok vous savez qu'on reprend
à gauche
alors là les halles à la les copains on
me la fait pas deux fois on me la fait
pas deux fois alors je bois du thé en
fait ce que je suis un mec vénère et là
je passe par la gauche direct easy money
allez on y va par la gauche donc j'en
sors d'amygdales ça c'est dégueulasse je
pense que [ __ ] je me suis bloqué un
truc dans le d'acord moi c'est bouché je
me suis kembolo un truc dingue ou bordel
mais du coup on va pouvoir retrouver
notre habitat au bras oui c'est notre
ami de bras oh oh [ __ ] lavage est
encore là que non ok c'est bien ce que
je pensais allez on y va on y va cash
[ __ ] de bordel deux noms elles sont
les huiles oui oui donne moi je dis non
moi je ne reste pas sans suite
alors du coup est ce qu'on va avoir une
seconde chance mais je crois qu'en fait
c'est ouvert au final suis-je bête
absolument nous a juste mettre deux
tartes en histoire de dire bon c'est qui
le patron ici on va prendre leçon des
quatre ans ferme et salut l'eau est
bonne dis moi tout au yes j'aime prendre
une douche
c'est cool et amadou voilà qu'on fasse
un slogan avec deux lamas but alors là
on a des magnifiques cailloux vers
est-ce qu'on peut pas à un si lourd
ok on continue attendez on va quand même
prendre une arme et au cas où comprendre
ce petit caillou la voilà très bien
je la remets ce n'est pas faire les
malins avec moi christophe dubrulle
jarman la bretonne
regardez j'ai tué un garde au
j'ai tué quelqu'un je t'ai dit c'est bon
c'est bon
cette technique marche à merveille nous
allons reprendre comment on fait pour
tourner j'arrive pas tweet [ __ ] de
touche pour tourner au bon dieu on a
utilisé un coup de trop allez on y va
e salut qu'est ce qui se passe ici non
non pardon soit en partance parce que je
voulais faire yes j'ai ramassé a media
luz danube oye aux mecs
[ __ ] il nous faut une arme ok je me
casse je go obtient je me chie dessus à
béthune qu'est-ce que c'était la main ok
eux doivent et par où la classe est
fermée avec un peu de chance on tombe
dessus et j'ai trouvé une porte études
caisse pierre fait juste monté les
marches et se barrer en mode je suis pas
le chef du propos alors est-ce qu'on
peut pas finir le niveau et venturi
jamais revenue en force alors première
porte à gauche
yes tu as trop étudié étudiait c'est mal
ça va passer à 1 1 des livres d'accord
très bien eux
oh mon dieu te serais tu fais je te
prends pas olalala mon pauvre mon pov
gars ont eu de quoi tu penses tu des
seuls les bilans de comprendre la ja
rien est ce qu'il n'ya pas quelque chose
ici non
une coupe bois bon rien non plus rien
non plus on va aller voir dans l'autre
chambre ma foi il n'y a même pas de
l'amadou non bon j'ai gagné le world cup
festival amnesia yes voulais me tester
given to stay n'a elle a disparu
bon on continue par là alors est-ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas une clé un truc
j'aime passer oui je vous le dire j'aime
vraiment passé bruit ces primes sont
stressés je les déteste bande de bâtards
je mets tout belle tiens voilà si
quelqu'un veut ma tach et cette poubelle
me protège un homme alors y'a pas l'air
d'avoir grand chose non plus finalement
dans cette salle tdr ce caillou non plus
dans ce tiroir
non oh là là je fous tout j'ai tu as une
campagne y'a rien là y'a rien là
bon bah on se casse un bras de fer de
plus de temps didon garde tableau voilà
une femme qui joue du violon avec des
vaches derrière qui seront tripoter par
un mec c'est la vie e
[ __ ] pourquoi mais pourquoi as tu as
fuck ténue ténue c'est pas bien c'est
pas bien c'est un garçon c'est là haut
tu mériterais une boîte de mode ou dans
les fesses elle continue par la hes qui
n'avaient pas quelque chose
desrochers
bordel c'est lourd au top arrêtez bordel
moi je donne des manèges de ne pas les
vêtements ok c'est quoi le problème
bordel de merde eux
alors est-ce que d'accord donc là on va
être cachés par des cailloux on est
comme en classe et que les bleus vont a
priori faut trouver un passage dans les
autres pièces je pense je sais c'est la
solution cloud tous absolument pas je
sais j'ai de l'autre solution non c'est
vite son temps en quittant en fait on
pourra jamais le dehors d'un désamour
c'est triste c'est très très triste une
foudre in cléon avis un passage dans une
des pièces là bas ou alors faut
carrément retourner en arrière j'en sais
rien c'est peut-être juste un attrape
couillon finalement c'est une chose papa
a annoncé cru km à coffre mais pas du
tout c'est un fake yes une note c'est
bon alors you will never get pis au
match tu fais toi toi qui s'est jetée
comme ça la mecque ou koutchma butin
génial quoi attendez on stars fait avec
avec les petits bruitages tu veux worm
habite non je ne vote pas d'accord tu me
fous la paix avec des bancs belge veut
rien voir chez vous mais chez moi trop
cool dans le dock des peines au col
alors du coup je suppose qu'il va
falloir retourner dans cette salle et
trouver la porte
trouver une autre porte où il faut une
clé bon sachant que cette salle je
n'adhère pas du tout je n'aime pas du
tout ce qui nous reste deux loups [ __ ]
on n'a plus beaucoup si si c'est mon
aiguille on n'a lui pas énormément mais
bon allez on va speeder faut trouver
ok ce que l'on peut voir ça yes
yes oh là là on est on est décidés à
gagner aujourd'hui
salut c'est là la fête des fleurs floc
floc floc floc blagues étaient nuls
est-ce qu'il ya autre chose à trouver
qu'est-il arrivé à notre bras il n'a
plus de chair et prends ton envol
salut non y'a rien bon bah on prend la
porte nous prenons la porte
salut oh là là là là ça sent pas bon là
ça sent les mecs les naked bike on les
appelle les gens nus qui courent vers
nous bonjour bonjour c'est ambiance
ghetto ce soit officiel des piscines
passons par la floride et l shears y est
bon bah écoutez les gens trouvent ça
fait un petit moment quand même qu'on
est dans le dans la vidéo alors on va
avancer encore un peu puisque là c'est
très intéressant tout ça où nous vous
idée très très intéressant est-ce qu'on
peut pas
bah
depuis on est mort voilà super tué par
un poisson dont amnesia bon je te
l'avais dit [ __ ] des mots mustela
riddick gvt confrères génère delà la
joie qu'on a atteint le summum de la
blague la plus pourrie du monde alors je
m'excuse d'avancé ceux qui ont trouvé ça
choquant âmes sensibles s'abstenir
allez on y va oui c'est j'écoute ma
lanterne du coup là du coup je dépense
mon huile bêtement a alors on repart on
prend soin de fermer la porte qu'il ya
des requins salut markov
non
yes au [ __ ] c'est glauque salut c'est
quoi cette pièce incroyable test can
wait custom tuerait et quand même pas
mal hein j'avoue merci d'avoir foncé les
gens tous sympathiques a surtout quand
on est dans le noir comme ça à vrai dire
j'adore super [ __ ] faut gérer le
poignet un pour ouvrir les portes
oh bordel oh [ __ ] mais je me suis
vraiment chaude par un mec cas tant dans
le jeu dans lola pédoncule électro
pressé de continuer à mais j'y crois pas
mais ça va là bon ben on va juste voir
ce qu'il ya au bout du couloir avant
d'arrêter cette première partie de cet
homme story ça commence à bien faire la
[ __ ] attaqué par des [ __ ] de
poiscaille c'est lourd à les [ __ ] il
est chaud là il est en mode 100 matelas
ou chaîne bol
ok on est chauds tête en passant à
droite roma wayne on entend passer à
gauche en mémoire à gauche on retourne à
gauche mettront le drapeau de la paix
que toi et ta g show ça me donne chaud
sans vous mentir up ou alors est-ce que
je me fais un one shot par un truc
inconnu non c'est bon des poules peut
l'être d'étendre la bourride taurine et
bien coûter sa fin de cette première
partie sur un edel jallet premier des
vidéos plus longue vous les avez je
pense qu'il y aura deux ou trois parties
en tout cas on se retrouve vendredi soir
pour la seconde
oa et regardez ils marchaient les
regarder ils nous disent au revoir tous
ces petits animaux
c'est magnifique
[Musique]